[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview of first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with the journalist and author
Rachel shabby and the political
commentator Benedict Spence so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now
well the telegrapher leads with the
coronation on the front page as you see
there the king and queen pictured
granny would be proud the mirror leads
with the prince of wales's tribute
the guardian has an exclusive with the
chair of the Royal College of GPS saying
NHS patients are developing cancer due
to Long weights
in the United States the treasury
secretary has warned of a constitutional
crisis if Congress doesn't raise the
country's debt limit
that's on the front of the Ft there
foreign
that by scanning the QR code you'll see
on screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us and we are
joined tonight by Rachel shabby and
Benedict Spencer welcome to both of you
let's start with the mirror and the
coronation the second day of festivities
that concert down in Windsor and Prince
William has just spoken giving a speech
in which he said rather movingly that
Granny would be proud of her son Rachel
take us into this
um yeah uh it's an interesting one isn't
it because uh you know he was talking
about granny being up in the sky looking
down fondly so it's you know it's a very
sort of playing to the crowd reassuring
thing to say I think he's also
you know the queen regardless of what
you think of the monarchy and I don't
believe in the monarchy as I think we've
established but regardless she was
personally a popular figure in the way
that perhaps the new king isn't and so
talking about the queen in that way is
going to obviously elicit uh uh a cheer
from the crowd and remind people and
cash in on on that Legacy as well
but he also said that he was proud of
his father
he did and I'm sure he is
um why wouldn't he be and you know we
saw him take part in the ceremony
yesterday which again a lot of people
found moving you know there's nothing
um to object to about his speech today
he's he's a very good speaker he
performs his role very well I don't
think anyone would doubt that Benedict
what did you make of the speech and uh
the whole coronation actually from
from Saturday oh well I thought I mean
the coronation is an interesting one
because I thought a lot of people from
what I sense a lot of people like people
I spoke to uh there was a sense of oh is
this it this isn't quite what we
expected it's a bit odd and you you do
get the that sort of feeling that it is
slightly out of place uh in the current
age given that only about one percent of
the population was alive when the last
coronation happened it is easy to sort
of forget but I was struck by some of
the symbolism that I'm sure actually was
lost on a lot of other people you know
the the sense of History actually going
back through the ages uh you know some
aspects of the service go back to King
Solomon you know when you think of who
it is that Charles is is related to
going back through through history
Vikings and Saxons going back a very
long time this is the sort of unbroken
chain which whatever your thoughts as
Rachel says on on monarchy are it's an
interesting chain link to our past and
all the symbolism that Charles brought
with that you know incorporating the
green man you know ancient British
paganism to having Faith leaders who are
not part of the Church of England you
know Jewish and Muslim and Orthodox
Community leaders at the Forefront of
the service I thought was an interesting
touch a nice touch in a lot of ways so I
understand why a lot of people thought
it was slightly out of Step but actually
I think it was quite nice it's about
more than just capturing people's
attention it is about a nod to the past
I thought William's speech was much more
about a nod to the Future it was quite
short it was sharp it was to the point
it did uh touch upon the late Queen and
how proud she would be as you'd hoped
she would be
um but I thought also interestingly
reinforcing the subject of service we're
not here necessarily to Reign Over you
and to be your Supreme overlords we are
here to serve that is the message that
the royal family is very keen to push
out for it to have a sense of purpose
going forward and I also thought it was
very interesting that the thing that
William really talked up was that King
Charles was ahead of the curve on
environmentalism before it was as he
said an important everyday topic uh King
Charles was the one back beating the
drum for sustainability for
environmentalism for climate change and
I think that you will see a lot of that
throughout his Reign not so much sort of
sitting there saying I told you so but
trying to lead the way on a subject in a
way that perhaps some politicians maybe
can't do perhaps he can be a sort of a
bridging figure across parties across
Nations I'm sure that is what he will
certainly hope to be doing and now that
Liz truss isn't in his way to stop him
from going to climate change conferences
I'm sure that he'll find that a little
bit easier and we look um at the front
of the telegraph with them quote from
Prince William's speech saying that Paul
we are so proud of you now Rachel I know
that that you're not a monarchist but
did you watch the coronation and what
did you think of the theme of to serve
and not be served that we heard much of
I mean it's an interesting one isn't it
because Benedict is right that they have
been very keen to make that message
clear
and I suspect that they have to do that
because
their power is fading
um the deference to them is fading I
mean I think we've had a media spectacle
and everybody is very effusive about it
but the reality is that there is
something extremely manufactured about
all this gushing because in polling we
have 60 of the population saying that
they're not very interested or not at
all interested in the monarchy you've
got 18 to 24 year olds the vast majority
of whom do not want to have a monarchy
clearly Society is changing clearly the
media has not caught up with that and
it's not reflecting that to cover to
cover the coronation in this way is not
reflective of a public mood and of
course the monarchy is going to say
we're here to serve because how else are
they going to keep their reign which a
lot of people no longer support or at
very least are disinterested in how else
are they going to keep it going they
have to say that and Benedict we have
the Prince of Wales um
referencing his grandmother and saying
that you know she would be very proud of
her son um how important do you think it
is to keep that link
um foremost in in the Public's mind of
the of the queen
what's important to remember everybody
now looks back very fondly on Elizabeth
II even though actually if you sort of
look at her reign in the hole you
wouldn't say it was a smooth ride and
there were times when the monarchy was
deeply unpopular while she was on the
throne and I think that actually that's
partly the link that you would draw from
this is that the popularity of monarchy
Ebbs and flows with how useful it can
find itself ultimately they are now sort
of gilded figureheads in in a cage sort
of Trapped By Their Own uh privilege and
power if you like they're unable to as
as Prince Harry has found it is not easy
you don't just sort of leave the firm on
your own terms it can't be done so I I
feel as a sort of an element of sadness
for them they do have to keep on trying
to find a reason to to go on but you
know I I think what what the late Queen
showed was that actually that you can
come back from from uh moments of
unpopularity uh by providing a sort of a
spiritual figurehead or just sort of
almost a community uh rallying point
that politics editions in this country
certainly I'm afraid just haven't been
able to offer we don't have the caliber
of public servant elected as public
servant who people are able to sort of
get around and even a lot of people who
I think are not particularly fond of the
monarchy or don't necessarily care I
don't think that they look at King
Charles or his mother I don't think they
look at them with sort of malice or a
massive desire to get rid of them it's
just a sort of a shrug of the shoulders
and going well this is what we have and
then when you offer them the
Alternatives they think is it that much
of it yeah is it worth actually the
human cry and the effort to change the
system now a lot of people could argue
that that's a fundamental issue with
Britain as a whole that it is too
lethargic when it comes to change but
that is the position that we find
ourselves in and I suppose steadfastness
in the face of Changing Winds across the
world was the calling card of Elizabeth
II and I'm sure that Charles would hope
that he could have that same sort of
steadfastness across his Reign Rachel we
turn to the financial times which um
according to their stats indicates that
that the royal family is still quite
popular around 20 million people just
under a third of the UK's population
that watch the coronation ceremony on
television and people across the UK held
more than 67 000 Street parties
well let's not conflate viewing figures
with popularity because I don't think I
don't think we can say with a straight
face that the 20 million people who
watched it are all die hard royalists no
I mean
that's not that's not a correlation the
67 000 Street parties what does that
tell them no I mean sure if
who would object in a street party you
know so these things these things don't
tell us about the popularity of the
Royals they tell us about other things
don't they and I think what's important
actually about this story in the
financial times it's one of the few that
has mentioned what also happened
yesterday which is the arrest of
protesters now Benedict was talking
about how
um the new King's environmental uh ISM
and being ahead of the curve of that was
recognized tonight and I I do think that
is true and I wonder what he would have
made of the police arresting just stop
World protesters yesterday who had no
intention of doing anything other than
revealing that they were wearing a
t-shirt and wearing and waving a placard
they were amongst some of the people who
were arrested yesterday and so you do
have to question what is happening in
this country where that kind kind of
oppressiveness over just wearing a
t-shirt or being a republican at a rally
in Trafalgar Square which you've already
told the police about and the police
have already said you can have and then
being arrested that's just for waving a
placard I do think we have to ask
ourselves very important various serious
questions about why and how that is
being allowed Benedict there has been uh
criticism it has to be said of the met
and them being too heavy-handed in terms
of dealing with the protesters and
somewhere MPS are calling for answers on
on this what what are your thoughts
that have been that have been calls into
the conduct of the Metropolitan Police
if they'd allowed them to sort of get
too close to the parade spooking horses
if there'd been altercations with people
on August as well no they would have
this is the thing actually I am not a
major fan of the Metropolitan Police but
I do believe in this situation they were
damned if they did they were damned if
they didn't we need to remember actually
this was not just about the coronation
actually this event this was an event
that saw heads of state from around the
world uh coming uh for for the
celebrations if you like you know
royalty presidents Prime Ministers from
all over the place so you can understand
why you know as much as I'm saying I
don't think that the Metropolitan Police
is particularly good at what it does you
can understand why the Metropolitan
Police was probably on heightened alert
as to absolutely anything moving because
one false step one thing goes wrong and
it's all on them and I think ultimately
you can look at this and you can go uh
it's not great but I think it's more
important to go back through the sort of
the Litany of things that have happened
with the Metropolitan Police and say
really this is something that we should
have foreseen coming and ultimately I I
can't get too heads up about it because
in the grand scheme of things are the
other things that the Met could have
fumbled this wasn't the worst thing I
understand it's very frustrating if you
are a protester but yeah of that day of
all days I think people probably should
have been aware the Met probably weren't
going to be on their friendliest at
their friendliest shall we say okay
we're gonna leave it there I think you
both made your points and it's obvious
that you're not going to agree on that
but we'll talk about more papers when we
come back coming up the impact on
patience of the long wait to see a
doctor will be discussing that and more
next
[Music]
thank you
if you are watching The Press previews
to with me journalist and author Rachel
shabby and the political commentator
Benedict Spence let us have a look at
the um
front of the financial times and this
story about Labor obviously setting
their stall out with the um the hope
that they might be back in power uh
sometime soon following a general
election but the government would
increase the stamp Duty paid by Foreign
buyers this is an attempt to to uh vow
to limit
foreign buyers of UK properties Rachel
says
once it wants to woo voters
um presumably voters who want to buy
Properties or want to buy property for
the first time potentially
um and I'm I'm not convinced that this
is going to cut it so they want to waive
they want to increase the stamp Duty for
a foreign buyers of UK property whereas
presumably it would stay the same for
first-time buyers and they're trying to
do this to stop overseas investors
buying properties in the UK which at the
moment is I think a quite a high array
and they want to introduce rules so that
for a certain period of time first time
buyers get a it's almost like first dibs
on new developments so that so that they
get a chance to purchase a property
my concern is that this isn't
this isn't what the obstacle is for
first-time buyers the major problem in
the UK is the giant lack of affordable
housing giant lack of housing stock full
stop and then within that lack of
affordable housing also people are not
able to afford to save
um to afford mortgages so there's all
kinds of problems within the housing
market it's just not it's not really
feasible to assume that this is what's
going to fix it Benedict do you agree
with with Rachel that that it's not the
the real problem for first-time buyers
yes after the ding dong that we had in
the first round you might yeah
we agree on this because this is the
solution actually to lots of things I'm
afraid is the lack of affordable housing
and yeah the figures are quite
interesting uh in this story it says
that in 2010 the number of homes owned
by overseas investors in the UK was 88
000 uh and that has jumped up in the
sort of uh 12 13 years since to 250 000
well we have a shortfall of about 250
000 homes not being built a year anyway
so it would only solve let's you know
assuming that all of those foreign
investors overnight most of whom are
very wealthy and therefore probably
won't be put off uh by an increase in
stamp Duty let's assume hypothetically
that they were all put off it would
address not even 10 of the overall
problem and of course another thing is a
lot of this is focused uh specifically
in London and I do understand a lot of
young people a lot of first-time buyers
are wanting to get on the property
ladder in London specifically but there
are other cities around the UK uh major
cities that also have housing shortage
issues as well so it's it's just it's
one of those things that I think labor
is probably focus groups and it probably
sounds quite good because it sounds like
they're getting tough on you know
overseas interference in British houses
it's doing good for British workers but
ultimately it's a drop in the ocean what
we need is a change in planning laws we
need affordable housing in this country
for young families and young people to
get on the property ladder and that's
not going to happen until somebody sort
of grabs the nettle and changes the law
about about making it easier to do so
yes they're quoting stupid executive
chair of the home builders Federation
saying that some large-scale
developments require upfront funding
that overseas investor buyers at can
provide and so a Nuance to problem there
let's look at this story about um Ed
Davey
um seemingly leaving the door open for a
lib Dem labor Coalition Rachel
yeah it's an interesting one because of
course labor keeps slamming that door
shut don't they
um and like this is off the back of the
local elections where uh the lib Dems
did all right they did well the greens
also did really well doubled the number
of seats uh labor did good but not as
well as they need to and the Tories got
absolutely hammered and of course we
have to slap a big caveat on this and
say people don't vote necessarily in the
general election in the way that they do
in a local election where there's
potentially more scope to vote for the
person you want if you want to vote
green or lib Dem you're more likely to
do that in a local election where
there's a chance of them winning so
there's that that's the caveat but then
we do have you know someone like John
Curtis the big um professor of
um voting politics and voting behavior
and he says that the performance of
Labor is not enough to win an overall
election uh election in the next
election an overall majority that it
would more likely be a hong Parliament
and that's where that's why you get
smaller parties like we're saying with
the lib Dems making these over tours to
labor but as I say so far um labor is
very firmly closing the door on that one
yes but labor very uh tight-lipped uh
Benedict can you see it where they might
be more moderate in in their um
welcoming of some sort of Pact
yes when they don't win the general
election and I think the only thing that
we can currently agree on is that the
Tories are likely to take a hammering
but of course that doesn't necessarily
mean that labor will win the majority at
which point this scenario would come
into play of course it's in Labor's
interest to say well we're not
countenancing that because that makes it
look like they don't think they're going
to win and that will shake people's
confidence and then people might wonder
why would I bother voting for them uh
the problem is of course the liberal
Democrats will remember the last time
that there was a coalition and that they
were in it and it very nearly destroyed
them and I imagine that the pound of
Flesh that they would demand from labor
would be significantly juicier than
whatever it was they got out of the
Tories I don't know what that would be
yet but I do think that they would make
it very painful for kirst armor it might
be to do with electoral reform not based
on a referendum uh this time you know it
would be something quite meaty and
something that meant that they didn't
get messed over so that if things did go
wrong as happened with the Coalition
they took the fall for it as we saw of a
student fees so you know wait to see I'm
sure that Davey is very keen for a
coalition because it's the only way
he'll get into power but I think labor
will be a little hesitant about the
prospect although in the end it might be
their only route in if things carry on
as they currently are we shall see just
time to have a look at this um quite
distressing story actually very worrying
front page of the Guardian that NHS
patients are developing cancer because
of long waiting lists to the the tuna
7.2 million uh on the waiting list for
NHS scans and treatment Rachel
absolutely horrifying as you say uh with
that long awaiting list it's inevitable
that people will get worse and
um you know while they wait because the
weights are so long and it's something
that doctors are also worried about and
you imagine when that applies to things
that are very very painful like if you
need surgery on a on a knee or a hip or
if you have cancer where the speed of
your care is of utmost urgency so this
is incredibly worrying uh and a
terrifying statistic really the the
length of the waiting lists
yes uh Professor Cameron Hawthorne the
chair of the Royal College of GP saying
the record delays for care and the
uncertainty of patients of when they
would finally be seen as leaving people
feeling helpless and forgotten